georges hilbert bejjani merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
où on l évolution de l'épidémie en
belgique
bonjour la situation en belgique est
stable elle est un sous contrôle donc on
attendait le pit compense cougnet en
tout cas la progression ne se fait plus
quand elle était au début et nous
attendent
quand même là t'es cru ça veut dire la
diminution des nouveaux cas hospitalisés
admis aux soins intensifs
on n'y est pas encore mais runje bientôt
motif d'espoir donc un peu comme en
italie pour pour la belgique mais les
hôpitaux est ce qu ils font face à une
saturation ou est ce qu'ils ont fait
face à une saturation comme dans
certains établissements français
notamment dans le grotesque ou en
ile-de-france mais non pas du tout donc
c'est la belgique comme tous les pays
européens n'a pas anticipé mais comme
l'épidémie a commencé ailleurs donc
comme vous l'avez dit en italie en
france
la belgique a pu réagir très rapidement
et le confinement a été instaurée
relativement plus vite que dans les
autres pays ce qui est ce qui explique
qu actuellement nous sommes à peu près à
60 % de taux d'occupation de nos lits de
réanimation sans compter les 10
supplémentaires disponibles qui peuvent
être mis en place grâce aux ventilateurs
des salles d'opération donc nous ne
sommes pas encore
dupont n'est pas du tout submergé mais
pour bien sûr la pression sur le
personnel soignant elle est très grande
justement le personnel soignant est ce
qu'il connaît un manque de matériel on
pense notamment aux masques de
protection ou au gel hydroalcoolique
c'est tout le temps tout juste j'ai
l'impression on travaille à flux tendu
parce que le matériel arrive mais il est
consommé donc au début de la crise j'ai
pu observer un peu de désorganisation
inquiétude une angoisse mais il n'y a
pas eu vraiment de rupture de matériel
on a anticipé en voulant tisser nomas
quoditienne aux blues mais au final le
matériel est arrivé est donc en tout cas
dans les hôpitaux que je connais autour
de moi il ira en sucre ysance de blues
de masques de lunettes et puis il faut
remercier aussi la société civile qui
sait
lisez pour mettre à disposition par
exemple des visières en plastique
gratuite
presqu'à un peu partout dans le pays
pour le personnel soignant
vous parlez de la société civile
justement dans quel état d'esprit se
trouve l'opinion publique en belgique
opinion publique les très compréhensive
en même temps elle demande un peu qu'il
y ait des comptes qu'ils soient rendus
après pour pour savoir pourquoi il n'y a
pas une anticipation de la part des
autorités mais aussi les hôpitaux dans
l'organisation et la préparation mais
sinon la population est très très
responsable comprend bien sûr la
situation et attend le conte puis ça on
peut circuler à nouveau
justement il ya un confinement également
du côté de la belgique depuis trois
semaines est ce que le fait que la
belgique soit mise sous cloche est ce
que ca va montrer des effets positifs
et combien de temps encore les belges
vont devoir rester cloîtrés chez eux
sont vous donc le confinement a été
certainement et j'insiste là-dessus
salutaire il est vrai qu'il était
difficile d'expliquer au quotidien les
raisons de chaque de chaque procédure
outre chaque décision qui a été prise
mais cela a été graduelle est donc
nécessaire
donc au début les masques par exemple
était réservée aux hôpitaux
le dépistage on en avait pas beaucoup il
était aussi réserver aux hôpitaux mais
actuellement les tests pour le dépistage
arrive de façon plus importante et je
pense qu'on va pouvoir envisager le
déconfinement comme on dit de façon un
peu plus plus structuré plus organisée
actuellement le confinement il est
encore de rigueur jusqu'à la mi avril
donc la fin des vacances scolaires ici
le 17 je pense et il sera peut-être
prolonger mais les modalités vont
commencer à changer à mon avis début du
mois de mai vous disiez tout à l'heure
dans vos propos que 60% de volition sont
occupées il reste donc encore environ
40%
quand on voit dans certaines régions
françaises
le grand test ile de france l'hexagone
est obligé de
de faire des évacuations comme
aujourd'hui va y avoir de très
médicalisé à destination de la bretagne
est-ce que la belgique pourrait ouvrir
ses portes pour accueillir certains
patients français attendu kobe de 19 est
ce qu'il ya des des liens entre vous et
vos homologues français donc je disais
60% je précise 60 % des lits de
réanimation
pour le reste c'est sûrement pas plus en
tout cas pour les dix hospitalier alors
en belgique comme en france vous le
savez aussi qu'en france tous les lits
ne sont pas occupés donc ce qui se fait
de transporter les patients d'une région
à l'autre est quelque chose qui est qui
et qui correct qui est logique en terme
de gestion de crise on a la même chose
en belgique ça veut dire que certaines
zones sont plus touchés que d'autres et
donc on commence à transférer certains
patients vers les hôpitaux ne sont pas
encore occupés
donc ceci a commencé déjà à une semaine
de la part de certains hôpitaux du
hainaut et de la région bruxelloise
sinon pour répondre à votre question
principale je suis un européen convaincu
et je pense que si jamais la situation
devait être dépassée dans d'autres pays
et que les transferts peuvent
s'organiser je ne vois pas pourquoi les
belges en tout cas les médecins belges
et le personnel soignant belge refuserez
cela les belges sont des européens
vraiment convaincus et déterminés dans
leur grande majorité et ils
accueilleront les patients
je suis certaine que à bras ouverts
merci gilbert mais gêné d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes un médecin anesthésiste et
président de l'association belge des
syndicats médicaux